Russia's Federal Security Service has
accused Ukraine of carrying out a car
bombing that killed Daria dugina the
daughter of a well-known Russian
Nationalist and close Putin Ally Kiev
has denied any responsibility in the
blast which happened near Moscow on
Saturday the allegation comes amid
speculation within Ukraine that a group
inside Russia could have been
responsible
shared by Russian Security Services
claims a female Ukrainian special
services contractor was behind a car
bomb attack that killed journalist Dario
dugina on the outskirts of Moscow on
Saturday they say the alleged Ukrainian
women moved to Russia last month and had
followed Mr Gina in a Mini Cooper she
then escaped to Estonia after the blast
but Ukrainian officials are denying the
accusations as propaganda
Ukraine surely doesn't have anything to
do with yesterday's explosion because we
are not a criminal State we're not a
terrorist state
but Mr Gina's killing has also sparked
wider speculation the national
Republican Army an unknown group is also
claiming responsibility for the attack
in a statement read by a former Russian
lawmaker and now host of a Ukrainian
online news show the group threatened
more attacks on people with connections
to the Kremlin
died at the scene after an explosive
device installed in her Toyota Land
Cruiser went off and the car caught fire
analysts believe her father Alexander
Dugan may have been the target Alexander
Dugan was meant to travel in the car but
reportedly later changed his mind both
Dugan and his daughter were on their way
to Moscow after they attended a cultural
Festival
Alexander Dugan is a staunch Ally of
Russian president of Vladimir Putin and
a far-right philosopher and author his
daughter was also a prominent member of
the ultra nationalist movement
supporting Russia's invasion of Ukraine
he called for genocide of ukrainians she
called ukrainians a sub-human race she
called for Public public killings of
Ukrainian prisoners of War Etc so yeah
she's a Dugan's daughter but she is
first of all a very active member of
Russian far-right nationalist Neo-Nazi
influential scene
meanwhile President Putin has paid
tribute to Ms dagina calling her death a
vile and cruel crime
for more on this now we're joined by D.W
correspondent Roman
conserenko in Kiev Raymond how credible
are these allegations by the Russian
intelligence service that a Ukrainian
woman was behind the car bomb
well one should be very careful with any
information coming from Russia
especially from Russian secret services
and if we are talking about the speed of
the investigation this is something
which is very astonishing we haven't
seen in the recent years maybe
um crimes in Russia being investigated
just within hours and evidence presented
on Russian television so um it is still
very unsighted the whole the whole case
seems very strange from here in Kiev
Russia is accusing Ukraine a country
which is at war with and Russia is
presenting a possible evidence Ukraine
is denying uh douging himself the father
of the victim is calling for Revenge
calling for victory over Ukraine the
next strange thing is how a quick
President Putin reacted he um sent his
condolences and awarded a medal to the
victim saying she was a Russian Patriot
and the Russian propaganda is also
running AI to call for strikes against
Kiev and this is something which also
struggle
looks strange for observers here it
would be very unwise of Ukrainian
government if Ukraine is
um behind us to do such an attack on the
eve of the Ukrainian Independence Day
which is on August 24th so a Ukraine
would know that Russia would could
retaliate for that and and bring many
people in danger and it is very unwise
to kill such a person just a few days
before
well you you mentioned it uh about the
possibility of retaliation How concerned
is the government in Kiev that Russia
May indeed use its version of events
surrounding to get his death to strike
at Ukraine
well those concerns are growing by the
hour
um just a few days ago Ukrainian
president zielinski warned that Russia
might be up to something bigger than
before we have reports that the
government officials are urged to stay
home not to work in the government
quarter the public transport will run
only until 21 hours there will be no
celebration like Ukrainian used to see
in the past 31 years on this day which
is very special so there are grave
concerns and concerns and there are also
reports in the media that Western media
than Russia that Russia might strike the
Ukrainian Capital Kiev something we
haven't seen for many many weeks and the
government quarter was not under attack
since the Russian invasion began so it's
a very tense extremely tense situation
here here in Kiev you can really feel it
in the air
Roman thank you very much our
correspondent Roman goncharenko there in
Kiev